I protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using Aura I get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so I
can fix the problem fast try Aura free
for two weeks using my link below
everyone welcome to the David packman
show I'm producer Pat Ford filling in
for David today as he continues his
paternity leave David should be making
his triumphant return to the show soon
relatively soon but he's of course
taking this time to enjoy himself as a
new parent and to spend some time with
the little one and get some sleep
whenever he can find the time to today
we're going to be talking about a number
of different topics we're going to be
talking about the January 6th hearings
we're going to talk about inflation and
gas prices and all these different
things but I wanted to start today
talking about gun control because
there's a new bipartisan deal in the
Senate on the topic of gun control and
it actually includes 10 Republican
Senators which is crucial because that
means there's a solid chance of this
actually passing in the coming weeks and
becoming law I don't want to celebrate
it too much because for one it hasn't
actually happened yet right and these
things could fall through we need to see
the actual text but also it seems a
little bit lackluster it doesn't come
nearly close to all the things that we
have to do to actually make a difference
when it comes to guns and gun safety in
this country but given the fact that
Republicans have been steadfast in their
refusal to do anything about guns in the
wake of mass shootings over the years
it's hard to not feel some level of
optimism over this announced agreement
the deal will include support for State
Crisis Intervention orders funding for
school safety resources an enhanced
review process for buyers of guns under
the age of 21 and penalties for straw
purchases that's when you have one
person purchase a weapon on someone
else's behalf the legislation will also
have a red flag provision so that states
and courts will have the resources to
make sure Firearms are kept out of the
hands of people who are at significant
risk of doing harm with them there's
also going to be increased funding for
mental health Suicide Prevention and
Trauma Intervention which is of course
an important aspect to all of this we
know that the right wing in this country
loves to claim that mass shootings are
all about mental health and that they're
just exclusively a mental health issue
we know that they just use it as a red
herring but there's there's something to
that right because that is one aspect in
all of this and we have to not only look
at gun control measures we have to look
at the mental health side as well so if
they're willing to have a good faith
conversation about mental health we
should absolutely take them up on that
and take advantage of it the 10
Republican Senators who have signed on
to this piece of legislation that's in
the works are John cornyn Tom Tillis
Richard Burr Roy blunt Bill Cassidy
Susan Collins Lindsey Graham Rob Portman
Mitt Romney and Pat Toomey the Centrist
Democrats who tend to torpedo pieces of
legislation that we like as progressives
and Democrats those are Joe manchin and
Kirsten Cinema they've also pledged
their support so this is very very
promising Joe Biden said about this
quote obviously it does not do
everything that I think is needed but it
reflects important steps in the right
direction and would make the most
significant gun safe safety legislation
to pass Congress in decades Alexandria
ocasio-cortez said about the bill if we
get a real baby step not kind of a
distraction from the solution she's
going to support it so both Biden and
AOC kind of providing the same sentiment
there that like yeah this is great and
all but we could just do so much more if
we had more willingness from the
Republicans to do anything about guns
sadly I think this is going to be
treated as the solution that's probably
what we'll see we'll probably see this
get signed into law and then they'll do
some sort of Victory lap and everyone
will pretend as if we actually did
something significant when it comes to
gun safety in this country when we know
we can just go so much further
um you know there are some solid
Provisions in this legislation that's
for sure but we know that we can do more
when it comes to Universal background
checks raising the legal age to own a
semi-automatic rifle to 21 magazine
capacity limits none of that stuff's in
there so maybe we can try with future
legislation but it's just doesn't seem
like it's going to be able to happen
anytime soon for as long as we have such
a slim majority in Congress and for as
long as Republicans are not willing to
compromise on much when it comes to this
issue so definitely go ahead pass the
Bill let's try to avoid the victory
lapse afterwards I want to see us try to
make this a voting issue come the 2022
midterms because it seems like now we do
have somewhat of a chance of maybe
holding on to the House and Senate it it
would be great too to pick up an extra
two Senate seats because that means that
we could potentially eliminate the
filibuster and do so much more and I
think you know this focus on abortion
and gun control at this point given how
the economy is might have to be the path
forward for Democrats the kitchen table
issues tend to be more economic and
financial issues and there's some
aspects of that that you know we're
having a tough time communicating about
because gas prices are so high inflation
so high so maybe given the Supreme
Court's leaked draft opinion when it
comes to a abortion maybe you know the
mass shootings and the backing for new
gun control measures that's going to be
enough to maybe Propel Democrats to hold
on to the majorities but we just don't
know yet and we really don't know what
the big issues are going to to be once
it's actually time to vote so that's the
latest when it comes to gun control it
looks like we're going to have some
piece of legislation pass through the
Senate and the house and that's very
good to see last Friday we got the new
Consumer Price Index data and we found
out that the inflation rate year over
year for the month of May was 8.6
percent there was this idea before the
numbers were released that maybe
inflation had peaked over the past
couple months and we'd start to head
down a little bit but this new data
release really throws a wrench into that
theory because we're still trending
upwards see albeit slightly in March we
were at 8.5 percent year-over-year
inflation in April we declined modestly
to 8.3 percent and in May once again we
went up to 8.6 percent it was predicted
by economist the head of the CPI data
release that inflation would go down to
about 8.2 percent so instead of being
slightly down we're heading slightly up
the Consumer Price Index or CPI is a
broad assessment of prices in the
economy including everything from food
to fuel to housing to discretionary
products the main reason for the CPI
increase appears to be that gas prices
have gone up quite significantly over
the past month or so gas prices due to
pent-up demand in the economy given you
know the recovery from the pandemic and
due to Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
other factors continue to go up they
just reached a record five dollars a
gallon and it's likely a trend that's
going to continue all summer long
because we know that gas prices tend to
go up with demand during the summer
months and certainly the situation in
Russia and Ukraine has not settled down
so we may see six dollar gallon gasoline
relatively soon who knows so it's going
to be difficult of course to have CPI
data going down when you have gas prices
going up so significantly if you're
going to do that you really have to make
up for it in the other categories that
it assesses and we just did not do
nearly enough to make up for it
interestingly enough though core
inflation which removes food and energy
from the index is at six percent for the
month of May year over year whereas in
April is at 6.2 percent so that's
positive that's heading in the right
direction but some people will say well
you can't just really take out energy
and food costs from the equation given
that there's such an important metric of
what takes place in the economy the CPI
release caused the markets to Tumble
quite a bit at the end of last week on
Thursday and Friday we saw the major
indices drop about three four percent
and the reason is that high inflation
means that the Federal Reserve is
probably going to have to be more
hawkish when it comes to raising
interest rates how often they're going
to raise the interest rates and by how
much because the idea is if you have
high inflation you have to cool down the
economy to encourage less spending and
that means that companies won't be able
to make as much profit which means that
investors won't make as much money which
means that people often will sell off
aside from raising the interest rates
which is really under the purview of the
Federal Reserve there's not much that
the Biden Administration can do when it
comes to inflation and gas prices that's
just a sad reality in all of this when
it comes to gas prices we know that he
can take more out from the Strategic
petroleum Reserve but that maybe will
save you 10 cents here 20 cents here
it's not going to be enough to
significantly Drive costs down and we
also know that the Strategic petroleum
Reserve really is meant for emergencies
so if there was a serious emergency that
came our way we had just released a
bunch of oil and gas that may not be the
best thing to do just about every
country we know is dealing with the high
gas prices and the high inflation so for
me personally I have a tough time
blaming Joe Biden for this the people
who think that Trump and Republicans
would do better I'd like to hear how
they would go about doing that I think
there's just a sentiment of well when
Donald Trump and the Republicans were in
charge we didn't have high inflation we
didn't have gas prices so clearly if we
put them back in charge they'd be able
to get a handle on it but that's really
just not how it works unfortunately the
average voter doesn't know about that
they don't know that presidents have
very little control over inflation and
gas prices so it's going to be tough to
communicate that to the American people
ahead of the midterms especially when
these really are kitchen table issues
can we afford gas can we afford these
other things because prices everywhere
going up so it's a big challenge for
Democrats heading into the midterms we
definitely want to focus on gun control
and abortion because we're thinking more
and more those could be winning issues
for us in November we also have to
effectively address how we're going to
try to get a handle on inflation and gas
prices even if it's just doing whatever
we can right to make some sort of effort
to appeal to people to vote for us again
so that's the latest when it comes to
inflation gas prices doesn't seem like
we have it under control yet many people
are shocked when their identity is
stolen but it's actually one of the
fastest growing crimes in the U.S I've
dealt with it it's a terrible feeling
and that's why I now protect myself with
aura one of our sponsors Aura monitors
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards and I can set it up to instantly
get an alert on my phone if something
happens and then Aura goes through the
process of fixing it as well Aura also
does things like make sure no one's
opening up bank accounts or credit cards
in your name or it takes all the tools
you need to protect all of your accounts
and devices puts them in one easy app
Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com Pacman you
can try Aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email pass
password right now and you can find out
for free I found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below Donald Trump has turned on his own
daughter and no I'm not talking about
Tiffany who Trump doesn't seem to have
the best relationship with I'm talking
about Ivanka who Trump once said that if
she wasn't my daughter perhaps I would
be dating her the context of this
betrayal goes back to the January 6th
hearings which began on Thursday we're
going to have day two of those hearings
tonight and they'll continue throughout
the week but last Thursday on the first
day there was video testimony from
Ivanka that was played and it showed her
basically saying that she did not agree
with the bogus election fraud conspiracy
theories as they were being made by
Trump and his allies and she instead
trusted the word of Attorney General
Bill Barr in his assessment that what
Trump and folks who were supporting him
were coming up with when it came to the
voter fraud stuff was just a bunch of
hogwash now we've known ever since the
beginning of the big lie that Ivanka and
her husband uh Jared Kushner were not on
board with the big lie they didn't want
anything to do do with it they wanted
Trump to conceive to Biden when it was
clear that he had lost and you know
Ivanka and Jared they're they're not
really the most ethical people but at
the very least they were not willing to
go along with parroting the lies of
trump and the people around him at the
time who were trying to end democracy
effectively in the United States but now
we're going a step further because it's
not just that Ivanka Trump is trying to
hide from the spotlight when it comes to
this voter fraud issue and either 2020
election stuff in general she's actually
had to make a stand when it comes to
this and she has with this video
testimony saying that yeah she thought
that with Trump and his allies were
saying at the time was bogus let's first
play the clip of what Ivanka said at
that testimony and then we'll go to
Trump's reaction uh told the president
in no uncertain terms that I did not see
evidence of Fraud
and you know that would have affected
the outcome of the election
and frankly a year and a half later I
haven't seen anything to to change my
mind on that
how did that affect your perspective
about the election when attorney general
Barr made that statement
it affected my perspective I respect the
Attorney General bar
so I
accepted what he said was saying okay so
nothing over the top there just a simple
yeah I agreed with Bill Barr's
assessment about the election and didn't
buy into the bogus voter fraud claims
but Donald Trump will not allow even a
modicum of criticism to come his way
from family members or from anyone else
and so he just couldn't help himself but
to take the truth social or Troth
Central as he likes to call it and he
had to post one of his truths as they're
called quite orwellianly so by the way
he posted quote Ivanka Trump was not
involved in looking at or studying
election results she had long since
checked out and was in my opinion only
trying to be respectful to Bill Barr and
his position as attorney general he
sucked so Trump is implying two things
there one that she didn't really mean
what she was saying she was just trying
to be a kind-hearted person and was
trying to stay on Bill Barr's good side
but also it's evident from this uh that
her opinion really isn't all that valid
right according to Trump because he says
that she's not well informed when it
comes to the 2020 election she checked
out she wasn't one of the primary people
studying the issue and that's
interesting because Trump and his allies
have been going around for the past year
plus talking about how the fraud was so
obvious that we can all see it right you
don't have to study it too extensively
you can just know by looking at you know
the voting machines and the dead people
voting and the ballot harvesting and all
of this nonsense stuff that clearly
there was election fraud in the 2020
race well if it's so clear that the
general public can see it how come
Ivanka Trump who had a role in the White
House and presumably wanted to keep that
role for the next four years during a
second Trump term how come she couldn't
see it well you know she just wasn't
looking into it strongly enough I guess
so obviously Ivanka is on the right end
of this but it's just fun to watch
because we know that Thanksgiving dinner
this year is going to be awkward at the
Trump Family Residence and you know I
think anyone else in Trump's position
after getting contradicted by by your
family member would just do your best to
ignore it right to keep shut but Trump
just can't help himself he had to take
the social media to complain about this
and you know I think this is probably
enough it's just you know barely enough
but I think it is enough to add Ivanka
Trump to the list of people who Donald
Trump has turned on over the years who
knew his own daughter she has made the
naughty list I talked about this next
story on last Friday's bonus show but
it's just such an important media story
I thought it'd be good to cover again
today for the General David packman show
audience and that is that as I was
watching day one of the January 6th
hearings last Thursday I couldn't help
but wonder is Fox News broadcasting this
because on the one hand it's a highly
relevant thing that's going on in the
world of politics so you'd think that a
news and politics TV station would have
to cover it on the other hand the
January 6th hearings are really making
Trump look bad really making his allies
look bad and even making Fox News
personalities look bad because you know
we found out about how Sean Hannity was
texting Kaley mcinanny as the capital
riots were unfolding trying to get her
to get the president to get his
supporters out of the capital on that
day well what I saw was Tucker Carlson's
show and they had a live feed up of the
hearing but they weren't playing audio
from it they were just showing the
visuals and Tucker went on the show and
he brought on guests and he was
complaining about how the whole ordeal
was overblown and how we're not talking
about the real issues because we're so
wrapped up at January 6th still uh
Carlson called the hearing deranged he
called it insulting and he took a moral
stand he said that he was going to
simply refuse to play along the lower
third Graphics during the show that's
the chirons at the bottom they were
saying things like January 6th committee
fuels false narratives as sham
investigation draws on there was another
one that said leaders will spend 90
minutes giving moral lecture a third one
said our leaders are focusing on January
6th while ignoring the real threats
here's a clip from Tucker Carlson's
opening monologue good evening and
welcome to Tucker Carlson you know it
tells you a lot about the priorities of
our ruling class that the rest of us are
getting yet another lecture about
January 6 tonight from our moral
inferiors no less an outbreak of mob
violence a forgettably minor outbreak by
recent standards that took place more
than a year and a half ago but they've
never stopped talking about it in the
meantime in the 18 months since January
6th gas prices have doubled drug od's
have reached their highest point ever
the US economy is now creating toward a
devastating recession at best
and scariest and least noted of all this
country has never in its history been
closer to a nuclear war
yet the other networks cannot be
bothered to cover any of that tonight
instead they've interrupted their
regularly scheduled programming to bring
you yet another extended prime time
harangue from Nancy Pelosi and Liz
Cheney about Donald Trump and Q Anon
the whole thing is insulting in fact
it's deranged and we're not playing
along this is the only hour on an
American News Channel that will not be
carrying their propaganda live they are
lying and we are not going to help them
do it
what we will do instead is to try to
tell you the truth we've attempted to do
that since the day this happened we
hated seeing vandalism at the U.S
Capitol a year and a half ago and we
said so at the time but we did not think
it was an Insurrection because it was
not an Insurrection it was not even
close to an Insurrection now it's also
interesting in all of this is that
during the entire broadcast they didn't
actually cut to a commercial break and
you have to wonder why that is right
because it's a TV show like any other
show you're going to go to commercials
every 15 minutes to give time for the
sponsors well what appears to have
happened is that fox Executives didn't
want people to have the opportunity to
change the channel right because if they
go to break it Fox maybe people will
tune over to CNN or another news station
and then maybe they'll come across the
hearings with the audio and then they
may actually learn a thing or two about
January 6th so couldn't have that which
meant that you couldn't have commercials
and that's really telling right because
on the one hand Fox is saying that
January 6th there was nothing Burger
there's too much focus on it it was just
a tourist visit nothing to see here and
on the other hand they're unwilling to
go to commercial breaks they're
unwilling to broadcast the hearing with
audio so they definitely have something
to hide when it comes to all of this and
they want to make sure that their
viewers don't learn too much more about
the events of January 6th and the lead
up now I'm sure we'll be talking more
about the hearings as they continue this
week but to be honest from day one of
the hearings I had mixed feelings
because I thought that the video
testimonies those were effective I
thought that the footage of the riots
and uh you know the Trump supporters who
are fighting with the cops and all that
stuff I thought it was very effective
what I didn't think was so effective was
some of the long-winded speeches and the
testimony from the police officer and
the documentarian and the focus on the
Proud boys and all that stuff I think if
it was a little bit more condensed it
would be more effective but that's just
my view anyway you're trying to appeal
to people who haven't made up their
minds when it comes to January 6th and I
think less is more when it comes to this
stuff so we'll get we'll see what
happens over the next few days as the
hearings continue if they are able to
engage with the audience any better and
if the public is able to come away from
this all thinking that there really
needs to be consequences for the people
who were involved on January 6 because
it was a terrible thing that happens in
our country and it should never happen
again this next story is just an
incredible display of hypocrisy from
Donald Trump and the so-called pro-free
speech right wing truth social the
Twitter copy that Trump made after he
got kicked off to Twitter about a year
and a half ago is reportedly Banning
users for being critical of what happens
to the U.S Capitol building on January 6
2021 there are a number of reports of
users claiming that their accounts were
suspended for talking about what exactly
happened on the 6th and talking about
the hearings and talking about things
that just simply make Donald Trump look
bad let's take a look at some of the
screenshots of people going to Twitter
to complain about how they were censored
on Truth social a username Jack said I
was suspended from truth social for
posting about the January 6th hearing
last night Donald Trump is scared of
free speech Joseph wrote just put out my
first post on Truth social and they
deleted it real freedom of speech Champs
there and then a user named Travis said
quote my truth Social account was just
permanently suspended for talking about
the January 6th committee hearings
including a screenshot of his account
being suspended and I feel like you
already know what the analysis is going
to be here this is just the most
hypocritical thing possible because like
the whole point of Truth social was
supposed to be that it was going to
allow for free speech and the free
exchange of ideas and they were not
going to censor people and ban people
needlessly and all these different
things but then you take a look at how
it's been in practice and it's basically
just been like the right-wing trumpian
version of Twitter which is fine if they
want to do that but it was marketed
originally as a free speech version of
the popular social media site so they're
not really doing the things that they
set out to to do and the second that
they see something that they don't like
that they disagree with stuff talking
about the insurrection and things
talking about Trump looking bad they
decide to take down the post they
suspend the accounts and there's
actually an argument to be made that
they're actually being more censorious
than Twitter is with some of these moves
that they've made so what exactly is the
point of Truth social I I don't know at
this point they're changing it day to
day it seems maybe it's just really to
make a site where Trump is able to speak
his mind and he needed to do something
that involved other users because the
blog posts that he had the official
messages from the office of the former
president that just wasn't cutting it
anymore and the bottom line is they
don't care about the hypocrisy right
Republicans in recent years they just
don't even respond to the points about
hypocrisy burning when we point out that
they're doing one thing and saying
another and what also isn't new is the
fact that truth social has these
policies because even before they
launched it was clear that they were
going to censor certain posts when it
comes to disinformation when it comes to
sensitive content and then they also
said something at the very beginning
which was that they were going to
prohibit posts that disparage tarnish or
otherwise harm in our opinion us and or
the site so on Truth social you can get
censored or banned for daring to
criticize Donald Trump or Devin Nunes or
the website at large and again this goes
to the point about this is actually more
censorious than Twitter is because it's
not like Twitter has an analogous policy
to this you can go on Twitter and
criticize Twitter you can go on Twitter
and criticize the executives there
clearly there's a line you can't cross
with the criticism right you can't be
like threatening anyone but you're able
to do generic criticism just fine on
Twitter and while we're on the topic of
Republican hypocrisy on this issue I
wonder if now that Republicans want uh
Twitter and these other social media
platforms to be regulated like Public
Utilities if they would say the same
thing about truth social if they want
truth social to be nationalized or
socialized I'm not holding my breath I
would imagine that they want it for
Twitter but but not for truth social so
that's just the latest on Truth social I
do think that we're going to be talking
more and more about it as the months go
on because it appeared at first that
this was going to die out because they
had a really bad launch from a tech
perspective and things weren't working
right and also there was the news about
Elon Musk planning to buy Twitter so
there was this idea that he was going to
allow Trump back on Twitter and at that
point why even have a social media site
of your own why not just go back to
Twitter but for now truth social is here
to stay and we'll have to continue
covering the blatant hypocrisy
Republican Florida representative Matt
Gates is probably not the wackiest
member of Congress or the dumbest member
of Congress I think we have to give
those titles to people like Marjorie
Taylor green and Lauren bobert and Louis
gohmert but Gates he has to be the most
despicable member of Congress right and
there's definitely some supporting
evidence for this like starting with the
fact that he's under investigation for
alleged sex trafficking and prostitution
of minors you really don't have to go
further than that although to be fair
he's only been accused at this point but
the investigation is well underway and
certainly the evidence against him
continues to mount but as if we needed
another example here is Matt Gates
chatting it up with Marjorie Taylor
green on Green's podcast and he makes
the case that Jamie Raskin who is
serving on the January 6th committee
shouldn't be allowed to serve on the
committee because his son died by
Suicide not that long ago and the trauma
from that must be clouding his judgment
that's how Matt Gates put it let's take
a look get the video clip what I worry
about with Raskin in all seriousness you
know when people encounter trauma they
often associate a lot of the other
things around that trauma with it even
if they don't naturally or or even
rationally associate maybe so and what I
what I worry about for the Congress and
for for uh Jamie Raskin you know no one
would ever want to lose a child
particularly uh to Suicide of course not
as a human being we actually our hearts
go out to him but yeah I think that he
takes that trauma and he Associates it
now with his work in the Congress to
such such an interwoven way that he's
unable to kind of do the Congressional
experience outside of the just the
dungeon of that personal trauma I think
it makes him look at it at everything in
these very like dark and severe ways
where you know we try to come to the job
really to uplift people to we're here to
serve the people well and we we love
this country
like you're out of a sense of of
grievance or hatred we love America we
love it and we want to vindicate the
rights of our citizens and we want to
Champion their causes and to battle
their dislikes but I think for Jamie
Raskin it's it's really like his service
in the Congress has almost become like
inextricably uh attached to this this
sad personal trauma he's had and I think
it does cloud his judgment uh and we
could see that that very darkness and
that pain manifest on on Thursday now
there's definitely multiple layers to
this story but I think the main one is
that Matt Gates really just has to shut
his mouth and not invoke the name of
raskin's deceased son to make a cheap
political Point like we know what he's
trying to do with this he makes this
disclaimer about how we're not you know
wishing death on anyone or trauma on
anyone democrat or republican but come
on like we know the point that you're
trying to make here the other layer to
all this is that logically it doesn't
really seem to add up either because
plenty of people experience trauma at
some point during their life times does
that mean that they have to quit their
jobs or you know not participate in
certain aspects of their jobs of course
not that doesn't make any sense and if
so like how much trauma is so much where
you're not able to perform your job
responsibilities the whole thing just
doesn't really seem to add up I don't
know why he decided to make this point
to begin with but this also goes to show
that Matt Gates is probably worried
about the hearings and the things that
Raskin and the other committee members
are going to uncover because we know
that Raskin certainly is a force to be
reckoned with and Matt Gates probably
can tell that the things that the
committee is going to uncover in the
next few weeks is not going to be good
for the trumpian right wing AOC also
responded to this statement for Matt
gates with a tweet she said quote rep
Raskin is a greater Statesman
Congressman human being than most of us
history will remember him Tommy was a
remarkable person and testament of his
parents love Gates is a bad haircut in a
cheap suit a feat of mediocrity given
that he's here on Papa's money buy so an
excellent point there from AOC you gotta
wonder if Gates regrets this comment
that he made because he really just
doesn't look good he looks dumb and he
also looks like he's insensitive when it
comes to this stuff so gotta Wonder does
he regret it I also kind of get the
sense that he's the kind of person who
would just double down and really not
care that he did wrong and not admit to
doing wrong with this also during this
appearance Matt Gates brought up the
idea of giving Nancy Pelosi a sponge
bath in what was an incredibly weird
moment Luke Beasley who hosted on Friday
he talked about this but I just had to
use this opportunity to play that clip
again let's roll it one more time is he
your least favorite member I have a lot
of mine I'm on record he set the top for
me like I would rather give Nancy Pelosi
a sponge bath than endure like one
dinner
totally but but just to just to bring
this I don't have the color for you okay
like like a lot of people would say
maybe Pelosi is their least favorite
member no
so here's how I feel about Adam big
yikes there that was an uncomfortable
conversation and probably another
example of something that would have
been better left unsaid during this
Marjorie Taylor green podcast appearance
and I'm wondering if Matt Gates is going
to be able to win his primary in August
or if he can win the general election uh
come November because certainly the
first district of Florida is very very
conservative but there's some real
accusations against him when it comes to
this child prostitution and sex
trafficking stuff that I think even many
members of the right wing are not going
to tolerate like if they're given the
option uh in Florida in this first
district of voting for Matt Gates who is
a trumpian Republican and a cartoon
character but also has these allegations
against him versus just another trumpian
Republican cartoon character they
probably go with the second one right
because there's a lot less baggage when
it comes to that hypothetical other
option that they have so I'm hoping that
this is the last seven months that Matt
Gates is a congressman and I hope it
comes to an end for him either because
he's facing some serious criminal
charges or because he loses his
re-election bid we should be finding out
relatively soon whether Donald Trump is
going to be indicted for his role in
allegedly trying to overturn the
presidential election results in Georgia
back in 2020 and the person who is
saying that the decision is coming soon
is someone who would know a thing or two
about it it's Fulton County district
attorney Fannie Willis who is the
Georgia prosecutor investigating whether
Trump broke election laws in the state
by trying to strong-arm Brad
raffensberger and get him to find the
quote 11 780 votes she told the
Associated Press that she expects to
come to a decision about whether to
indict Trump by June 30th now that
sounds very direct and it definitely
sounds like it's coming soon especially
because were in the middle of June now
but then he find out there's a catch in
that that catches that she actually made
the statement back in January she said
quote I certainly think that in the
first half of the year that decision
will be made but who knows if between
now and then things have changed if the
timeline has been moved back what is
promising though is that Willis has been
ramping up her investigation in recent
months she's interviewed a few dozen
people including Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger she was granted approval
for a special grand jury but has held
off on having Witnesses testified before
the Jury Willis has also commented that
she would want to make the announcement
after the primary elections as to not
give the appearance of a conflict of
interest or trying to influence the race
in any way and those primary elections
took place a few weeks ago in Georgia so
now around now seems like the right time
to come out with the announcement right
are you going to indict him or are you
not especially because if she's worried
about this idea of Allah election
interference then you know you don't
want to wait so long as to run up
against the November midterms you don't
want to wait until right before the
general election either so I'd imagine
it's probably coming soon to me for what
it's worth I think that Trump clearly
broke the law on this I think it's a
slam dunk case if you look at the
Georgia election law it says quote a
person commits the offense of criminal
solicitation to commit election fraud in
the first degree when with intent then
another person engage in conduct
constituting a felony under this article
he or she solicits requests commands
importunes or otherwise attempts to
cause the other person to engage in such
conduct and the punishment is somewhere
between one and three years in prison
for what it's worth and I'm no lawyer
but if you take a look at the letter of
the law there it certainly looks like
Donald Trump committed this crime and
you at least have enough evidence to go
to an indictment and we'll let the jury
decide whether he is guilty they also
have audio recordings of him they can
establish that there was a well-planned
well-coordinated effort to do this
certainly wasn't a one-off thing by
Trump too like he definitely has a
pattern of this and there's Witnesses
like you definitely have a solid case
here so my sense is that if they decide
not to indict it's going to be more of a
political calculation than a criminal
one they may just say you know we've
never prosecuted a former president we
don't want to go down that road so we're
going to let him off the hook here and I
hope that doesn't happen I hope that
he's held accountable also someone who
thinks that Trump is going to be
indicted in this Georgia case is Eric
Holder who was Obama's attorney general
let's take a look at him saying that he
suspects an indictment is going to come
soon I think you know you can look at
what Merrick Garland is going to do I
think my primary my first analysis would
be what's going to happen to him in
Georgia well you've got him on tape
saying you know find me 11 781 that one
is close to a layup it seems to me
I've always said the same thing about
that one why don't they just go after
that one moment it's on tape you have
the Smoking Gun he's saying I mean I
remember when Rod Blagojevich right was
on tape basically it didn't work out too
well for him no I know but but it was it
was it was it was pretty blatant but it
wasn't as bad as find me 11 000 votes
yeah yeah no I think as I said I think
that's close to a layup uh the D.A down
there is going to be calling Witnesses I
understand before a special grand jury
but the interesting thing there is that
that can also be a specification in a
federal charge that could be brought in
Washington D.C when you're charging him
with conspiracy to defraud and
conspiracy to obstruct what happened in
Georgia can actually be part of a
federal case as well so I think you know
I was a federal prosecutor doing
political corruption cases when I first
came to the justice department for 12
years and you get a feel for these
things after a while I get the feeling
that I can see where this one is going
and a lot of high-level people in the
Trump Administration I suspect the
president himself people at the justice
department are all going to find
themselves on a little document that
says the United States versus fill in
the blank so there you have it Eric
Holder suspecting that Donald Trump is
going to be indicted in this Georgia
election fraud case and I just get the
sense that if Trump is going to have to
face any consequences for his alleged
wrongdoings it's going to be because of
this Georgia case like the other
investigations I just don't see them
going anywhere at this point the one out
of New York for example there just
doesn't seem to be the appetite to
charge him and we've had resignations
because it seems clear that they're just
not willing to go in that direction
Merrick Garland and the Biden justice
department I just don't know if they
want to open up a can of worms and start
this tradition of presidents Prosecuting
former presidents Trump probably could
get charged for his alleged Financial
crimes and his role in the Insurrection
and the hush money payments that he had
Michael Cohen allegedly issue and that
Cohen went to jail for but to me this
one just seems like it has the highest
chance of actually getting an indictment
going to trial and getting a conviction
so we'll see how it goes we're going to
find out whether Trump will actually
ever have to face consequences for
anything in his life
Kyle Rittenhouse is doing his rounds in
conservative circles and the latest on
him is that there's actually a dispute
between him and Texas A M University
over whether he's going to be going to
school there in the fall and taking
classes Kyle said recently on the
Charlie Kirk show that he was going to
be going to the university the
university however says otherwise they
say that he has not been admitted and
won't be taking classes there how on
Earth did this happen let's first go to
the clip of Kyle explaining to Charlie
Kirk that he is going to become an Aggie
and putting on the Texas A M cap to
celebrate he's ready
he's ready to make it wow everybody it's
a big deal
right here in the Charlie Kirk show Kyle
Rittenhouse is announcing that he's an
Aggie so I'm going to be going there
it's going to be awesome beautiful
campus amazing people amazing food
um we went to Dixie's chicken there
best burgers I've ever that's why he's
going Dixie's chicken everybody now you
know what they say at a m they say
giggum gig em and you know how they say
hello they say howdy howdy so there you
go and so you're gonna you're gonna be
are you gonna join the core Cadets I
haven't decided yet I may
um well that was all very interesting
but the university disputes Kyle's claim
on this Kelly Brown who's the
spokesperson for Texas A M should quote
he has not been admitted as a student
this summer or fall now typically when
you have one person claiming one thing
and another person claiming another you
have to sort of weigh the arguments to
determine who's in the right and who's
in the wrong or maybe who's telling the
truth and who's not telling the truth
with a case like this though it's pretty
clear that whatever Texas A M says goes
like they're going to be the correct
ones and all this because it's up to
them right if they don't want to allow
him as a student at the school then he's
not going to be going to that school and
that's just kind of the end of that like
I could say that I'm going to Harvard or
Yale or wherever to take classes but if
those schools don't actually admit me
then I'm not going to be going to those
universities but with regards to this
Texas and a m situation I just wonder
exactly how it happened right like was
he sent a denial letter but he thought
it was an acceptance letter was he
initially accepted and then they decided
to rescind the acceptance was there just
some incredible misunderstanding what
exactly happened I mean maybe there was
a planned charade with all this where he
wanted to force the University's hand
into allowing him to go to the school
and maybe he wanted to make some broader
points to a right-wing audience about
liberal indoctrination and cancel
culture at college campuses I'm just not
exactly sure funny enough Kyle has been
working on a grift he calls the media
accountability project or tmap I don't
know why they didn't just go with map
for the acronym they went with tmap but
tmap has the purpose of suing people for
defamation and going after the corporate
press because Kyle felt like he was
defamed during his murder trial and so
he wants to get revenge against a bunch
of people but it's like one of those
things where Kyle if you're going to be
doing this if you're going to be working
for tmap you can't be going on Charlie
Kirk's show and saying things that
aren't true because maybe the
organization is going to have to go
after you uh before this Kyle was taking
classes at ASU Arizona State University
and he dropped the classes to focus on
the homicide trial he wanted to resume
classes there after the trial ended but
a bunch of students had an uproar and
the university decided to cut ties with
him he said in a follow-up tweet that
actually he's going to be going to Blinn
College a community school out in Texas
tweeting unfortunately the end of my
high school career was robbed from me I
didn't have the time other students get
to properly prepare for the future I
look forward to attending Blinn College
District this year a feeder school for
Texas A M I'm excited to join Texas A M
in 2023. so apparently he's going to
Blinn College although how can we know
for sure because he wasn't exactly
accurate when it came to the Texas A M
situation so maybe in a week or two
we'll find out that he actually wasn't
admitted there and wouldn't that be
something thing and you have to wonder
also if this is going to cause a wave of
students to leave Blinn college to
transfer somewhere else because they
just don't want to associate with Kyle
Rittenhouse and I feel mixed feelings
about that sort of thing because on the
one hand those students have every right
to transfer if they just don't want to
associate themselves with Kyle on the
other hand Rittenhouse was put through
the criminal justice system and he was
found not guilty by a jury of his peers
and so there's this idea that he should
be allowed to rejoin society and that
can include seeking higher levels of
education and trying to better himself
and all these different things so I do
think he should be able to go to college
somewhere but when you're talking about
some specific college that has to let
him in or doesn't have to let him in
that's where it gets tricky because the
colleges have every right to make their
own decisions the students who go to
those schools they have every rights to
make those decisions so that's the
latest on Kyle Rittenhouse apparently
becoming a college student in the fall I
have for you today one of the funniest
moments from conservative media in a
while it comes comes to us from oan and
they were doing this fluff piece about
Donald Trump they were calling him a
great president great Patriot and they
had the sentimental music going on in
the background it's not even clear
exactly why it was relevant to be doing
right now as a story but they were doing
it they were showing that they have
Trump's back for the 2024 election if
and when he decides to run and right
after this sentimental piece they did
they cut to a commercial break and what
commercial was it but Viagra to make a
really awkward transition that will go
down in television history let's take a
look at the clip
we here at one America news would like
to say thank you president Trump
your legacy as a patriot is
unquestionable you have inspired
countless millions and shown our nation
what it truly means
to make America great again
for one American News
I'm Pearson sharp generic Viagra
delivered within 48 hours in discrete
packaging on approval no one will know
but you
look and your mailbox rexmd.com is the
fast easy and affordable way to get
generic Viagra now that is just the best
isn't it that is comedic gold right
there going from that sentimental News
segment right to a Viagra commercial and
you have to wonder like did they not
realize that they were going to be
throwing to a Viagra commercial right
away so the transition will be a little
bit awkward did they not realize that
the segment was going to be so heartfelt
and sentimental like what exactly went
wrong there and I feel like with oan you
kind of have to wonder are they all just
trolling us over there to the right wing
commentators on that Network are they
are they serious are they just playing a
character what exactly is going on
because it just seems so out there most
of the time that you have to think like
they can't actually believe this stuff
do they really believe this stuff maybe
they are just trolling all of us and in
terms of transitions being awkward on
television that probably comes in first
place the one thing that would maybe
rival it though is back at the beginning
of the year when Russia had just invaded
Ukraine there was a lot of coverage of
the war there on CNN they were showing
the sirens going off at one of the
Ukrainian cities followed up by a
Applebee's commercial that really wasn't
the best transition either let's take a
look at that one
[Music]
so you'll all have to tell me which one
you found more Awkward the oan
transition or the CNN transition and to
me it's easier to laugh at the oan one
because the CNN clip had some elements
of tragedy to it right with the war
going on whereas the oan one you could
just take a look at that and be like
what exactly is going on at that Network
so that's the latest on oan we don't
talk about them too much anymore but we
absolutely had to cover this story Sarah
Palin former Alaska governor and 2008
Vice Presidential nominee for the
Republicans she is running for congress
as we know she's trying to make a
comeback into public life after a long
Hiatus and she has now passed the first
hurdle for getting the job this is
actually a special election that's going
on in Alaska since Don young died
earlier this year after representing the
at-large district in Alaska for 49 years
now Alaska has this interesting system
where they have all of their candidates
regardless of party appear on the same
ballot for a first round of voting the
top top four vote Getters then move on
to the next round of voting where ranked
Choice voting is used to determine who
comes out on top we just had the first
round of voting and we're still getting
the votes in but as of now the results
show that Palin has 29.8 percent of the
vote followed by another Republican
named Nick begich at 19.3 percent then
we have Al gross at 12.5 percent and
Democrat Mary pelota at 7.5 percent so
those should be the four who advance and
move on to the second round notably not
making the cut yet still getting an
impressive 4.5 percent of the vote was
Democratic Socialist candidate Santa
Claus which I didn't realize that Santa
lived up in Alaska I thought he lived up
in Canada or like maybe the
international territory that makes up
the North Pole but apparently he's an
Alaska resident and who knows maybe
he'll get him next time uh Palin's near
30 percent in the vote is a commanding
lead ahead of everyone else but then
when you note that there's something
like 50 other candidates you have to to
think about how the other voters are
going to coalesce when the candidate
number drops down to four also you have
ranked Choice voting so that makes it a
little bit harder to predict compared to
a normal election so who knows what will
happen in the second round uh you just
don't know who people are going to
coalesce around maybe the other
Republican will do better in the second
round maybe the independent Al gross
will win there's a good chance that
maybe she's not able to pull this thing
off and that would of course be a major
blow to Trump's endorsement record and
to the state of trumpism in this country
because not only is Palin endorsed by
Trump she in a lot of ways was Trump
before Trump was Trump notably based on
how incompetent and inarticulate she was
and we didn't realize that someone so
unqualified could serve in public office
at such a high level but you know then
we got Donald Trump and now it's
somewhat normalized also not helping
Palin and Trump is the fact that Alaska
politics are a lot different than the
rest of the country they tend to be more
Centrist and they like the more
reasonable candidates more often than
not so who knows if she can pull it off
there it's really just not the reddest
state in the country plus many alaskans
view Palin as a quitter because she quit
her job as Governor 10 plus years back
to do a reality TV show so that just
didn't sit very well with them how do
they know that she's not going to resign
early from her seat in Congress but fear
not because Palin has an excellent
excuse in her back pocket in case she
doesn't come out on top she went on Mark
Levin's show a few weeks ago and she
said that you know if I don't win
clearly it's because of voter fraud yeah
she's using that routine let's take a
look at this clip from about a month ago
yeah whether I have a a good shot or not
they're they're I think about 50
candidates in this race it's a real
bizarre race
50 and Mark you'll just really
appreciate this it's mail-in only
ballots uh no hand counting to tabulate
got to go through a Dominion computer to
count everything and um
I like yesterday Mark I received four
ballots in the mail I didn't even ask
for any ballots uh one for one of the
daughters who doesn't live here did she
hasn't haven't cleaned residency in
Alaska since she moved outside
um we call anything outside of Alaska
I'm trying to say murkowski
oh well um you know who wrote this
bizarre election plan that we have right
now going on with the ranked Choice
voting that's coming up and the mail and
only ballots and all that was Lisa
murkowski's attorney unbelievable
yeah I mean do I do I have a shot at it
yeah I I have a shot at it um it's it's
bizarre though you know um this kind of
voting system so I hope the rest of
America keeps track of what's going on
in Alaska so it doesn't happen to them
well that's certainly The trumpian
Playbook right there if you win
everything was on the up and up and you
just got more votes from the good people
of your District to your state but if
you lose you didn't really lose it was
just rigged and what can you do you were
a victim so that's nice you have that in
your back pocket as an excuse and you
can really use it in any election that
you want to of course I want Palin to be
defeated and there's really a good
chance of that happening we'll have to
see it's going to be tight but maybe
this is a race that we can get ourselves
involved in uh but part of me wonders
like if Sarah Palin does become a
congressperson would that have
entertainment value would she have these
wacky off-the-rail speeches on the house
floor that would be worth watching I
also wonder if she would interact well
with people like Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Lauren bobert would she be too crazy
for them would they be too crazy for her
I just don't know so you know if she
does end up pulling off the win in this
race that will be like the one Saving
Grace we get to see how she functions as
a member of Congress but hopefully it
doesn't get to that and hopefully Sarah
Palin is defeated when it's time for the
second round of voting of course
there'll be more elections to come and
we'll be following all of them all right
thanks very much to David for allowing
me to host Today's Show and uh if you
want to check out the bonus show make
sure to become a member at
joinpakman.com or go to patreon.com
davidpackman show and contribute at the
five dollar level I'll see you there
foreign
I protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using Aura I get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so I
can fix the problem fast try Aura free
for two weeks using my link below